bonsoir nous sommes le 18 octobre
nouvelle édition du 7 8 en direct à 18h
nous allons faire le point sur
l'actualité du département au cours de
la prochaine heure et sur ce plateau
françoise jeanneret bonsoir vous avez
résidente de l'association yvelines
environnement association de défense de
l'environnement depuis 1983 avec vous on
va parler de l'éolien puisque la région
ile-de-france a adopté fin septembre son
schéma régional éolien 100 à 180
éoliennes pourraient ainsi être
implantée d'ici à 2020 en ile de france
vous nous direz ce que vous pensez de ce
projet j'accueille aussi sur le plateau
alice gastines bonsoir servait comme
tous les jeudis avec vous la chronique
de l'écho ce sera dans un peu moins
d'une demi heure ce soir oui alors il
sera question d'une toute nouvelle
initiative de la mairie d'elancourt un
contrat d'autonomie pourrait l'aider
pour aider les 18 25 ans à s'insérer
dans la vie professionnelle et puis ce
groupe de députés génération entreprise
qui avait été créée par jean michel
fourgous ancien député des yvelines qui
vient d'être relancé avec des
propositions pour relancer la
compétitivité des entreprises notamment
la page est qu à suivre ce soir et puis
bien sûr nous reviendrons sur cette
annonce d'alcatel de supprimer
5490 emplois dans le monde
le site de vélizy serait concerné plus
de détails dans quelques instants le
reste du sommaire de ce 18 octobre à
présent en images le maire de plaisir
joël regnault a confirmé qu'il quittait
son fauteuil de maire tout en restant au
conseil municipal
il s'expliquera officiellement sur sa
décision après la notification du préfet
en attendant nous avons recueilli les
réactions des plaisirs wa que vous
pourrez entendre
autre départ surprise celui de sylvie
faucheux l'actuelle présidente du pôle
de recherche universités paris grant
west elle a été nommée hier rectrice de
l'académie de dijon elle prendra son
poste dès ce vendredi dans les yvelines
il n'existe qu'une seule éolienne
implantée sur un site à guîtres en cours
près de mantes la jolie d'autres
pourraient suivre un plan régional de
développement éolien vient d'être
présentée 109 communes peuvent
potentiellement être sélectionné pour
accueillir un tel projet reportage
réaction donc de l'association yvelines
environnement sur ce plateau la semaine
du commerce de proximité vient de se
terminer 4e édition qui a permis de
faire le lien entre la population et les
commerçants locaux ce sera l'un des
sujet de la chronique économie ce soir
et puis sachez que jean frédéric poisson
le député du parti chrétien-démocrate
ump de la 10e circonscription des
yvelines sera sur ce plateau pour
évoquer son choix de soutenir jean
françois copé face à françois fillon
vous entendrez aussi le point de vue des
autres élus du département
l équipementier en télécommunications
alcatel-lucent va supprimer
5490 postes dans le monde
3330 en europe dont 1400 30 en france
c'est notre chiffre du jour c'est ce que
nous avons appris aujourd'hui jeudi 18
octobre auprès des syndicats la
direction a confirmé ces chiffres nous
avons en ligne et didier ringot bonsoir
bonsoir d'idées ringot délégué syndical
cgt alcatel sur le site de vélizy vous
êtes également délégué du personnel sur
ce site quelle a été votre réaction
lorsque les chiffres ont été
officialisés 1430 postes supprimés en
france
chiffre important mais n'a fait que
beaucoup plus fine et d'autant que nos
chiffres mondiale famille 490 fait même
supérieure avec l'annoncé en juillet
2000 suppressions
l'europe est particulièrement touché la
france est particulièrement touchée
demain vendredi 19 octobre sur le site
de vélizy il y aura le comité central
d'entreprise où sera présenté la
déclinaison de ce plan pour alcatel
france et les conséquences forcément sur
l'emploi sur les emplois à vélizy est-ce
que vous avez des inquiétudes
particulières sur ce site de vélizy où
vous êtes délégué du personnel notamment
le risque d'être
fortement concerné parce que les
activités enfin les métiers qui sont
vidés par les suppressions d'emplois
c'est quand même tout ce qui est autour
des fonctions commerciales donc sont
très présentes sur le site de vélizy
donc peu parce que beaucoup de
suppressions de postes surveillez
donc
en même temps une aussi le
renouvellement du bail qui est encore
des négociations et que
quand même que
cette firme est donc le site de muri le
site de vélizy qui donc pourrait
éventuellement fermer on en saura plus
et vous en serez plus les salariés sont
bien sûr les premiers informés de cette
situation
dès demain vendredi lors de ce comité
central d'entreprise merci didier ragot
d'avoir été en ligne avec nous pour ses
premières réactions et puis je vous
donne également une information ensuite
à l'annoncé de ce plan social jeudi en
fin de matinée la bourse de paris le
titre alcatel avait s'adjugeait plus de
5,5 pour cent une progression en bourse
alors que des emplois vont être
supprimés
demain à vendredi les salariés en seront
plus nous ferons le point également dans
notre prochaine édition je vous rappelle
que 1430 postes en france et près de
5500 au moins dans le monde vont être
supprimés par alcatel